hot breath any you'll ever see at
voiceroast.com bossroast.com
i saw the trailer that's all i saw it's
the best roast
it's it's it's murderer's row colin
quinn jim norton bobby kelly
florentine big j jerosha bonnie
judy gold murderer's row yeah it's it's
a different
it's a different game up there in new
york you guys
you guys don't don't use gloves up there
it's all bare knuckle up there
we're real yeah we're not thin skinned
you know like these young comics
you say something negative they go oh
what's that about it's about a joke you
idiot
all right you're a comic all right
so you know i mean i'm from a
a crew of honest ball busters
kevin hart patrice me norton
keith billy you know
i mean kevin hart and billy are doing a
little better now just
much better than much better than the
patrice but
some say patrice got out just in the
nick of time before he was gonna have to
start working like that
patrice would have been the best comic
out now now well the best to me
the probably the best comic in my
opinion is stan hope
he's probably he's definitely no
it's it's weird stan hope colin quinn
billy louie
and me and you of course i was going to
put you at the top of that list
no i'm not at the top but see i could do
things that people just can't do
in this business i'm just so versatile
you know when it comes to i could do any
crowd
doug stanhope is a genius but he can't
do any crowd
well maybe he can now he can't do kids
[Laughter]
what's the what's kind of the the secret
behind being able to do every crowd
living life and having experience in
life and just knowing people
just being real could you mention you
come from like comics that are real is
that something
younger comics lack is just that real
a lot of them are good writers but
they're doing comedy from the head
nothing from the heart but maybe you
know takes time to find your voice
you know you got these young guys
they're great writers or young girls
but
when they leave or they're done how much
do you really know of them
not saying you have to know a comic
that's just my style i like
you know i'm pretty honest on stage
about my life and different things and
how i
view things but it's all great different
types of comedy i mean they're all great
you know you get somebody like brian
regan
he's as funny as anybody who's ever been
alive everybody
you know and then you go to the other
spectrum you get someone like i stand
hope like you said or louie and they're
just as you know
and you know you get maria bamford who's
as funny as anybody yeah
who's ever been alive you know and then
you get
uh you know just the opposite
but that i mean maria's in her own look
at this
maria's in her own
category because she's so funny and and
so different
coming to see you so out of her mind
you